GOOD. THE RULES COMMITTEE OF FOR
THURSDAY MARCH MAIN.
WE HAVE SOME AUDIO ISSUES SO WE
WILL JUST PERSEVERE. OF GOOD
MORNING THE RULES COMMITTEE OF
THURSDAY MAY NINETEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY TWO IS HEREBY CALLED
ORDER. IS YOUR VISOR AUDIO VIDEO
RECORDINGS BEING MADE OF TODAY'S
PROCEEDINGS THERE'S ALSO BEING
TELEVISED- THERE IS A POWER
OUTAGE AFFECTING THE MAINSTAY
CAPITAL BUILDING SO- IN RESPONSE
THAT WE'VE JUST RELOCATED ARE
HEARING THIS MORNING- ADAPTING
THAT NEED. UP MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC ATTENDING THIS HEARING
OCCURS WHERE MASK AT ALL TIMES.
ATTENDEES BASALTS REFRAIN FROM
CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS DISTURBS
OR OTHERWISE IMPEDES YOUR EARLY
CONDUCT OF THIS HEARING.
VIOLATION VISUALS BY SUBJECT
INDIVIDUAL TO REMOVAL OR OTHER
ENFORCEMENT PROCESS. MR
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AND I DO AS PEOPLE SHOUT OUT.
THERE CLEARLY HEARD.
SENATE GENDA. MOVED BY MISS
WALDRON SECONDED BY MR FONG
ARMOR SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE
WALDRON WALDRON HIGH BENNETT AND
HI FLORA FONG ON HIGH GIPSON
GIPSON HI WE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MATHIS RUBIO THE
VALLAPUDUA. YOU COULD Y. OF THE
MOTION IS PASSED AND I THINK YOU
ALL FOR JOINING ME AND THIS
RULES COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED. ON
WORD AND.